now imagine this flying anywhere else
last night Don Lemon thought it was
hilarious when guests on his show mocked
Kanye West's intelligence ahead of the
rapper's meeting with President Trump
Thursday tomorrow and it was done in the
most offensive way possible
watch Kanye West is what happens when
Negroes don't read and and we have this
now and now Donald Trump is going to use
it and pervert it and he's gonna have
somebody who can stand with him and take
pictures he's an attention [ __ ] like
the president he's all of a sudden now
the the model spokesperson he's the
token negro of the of the Trump
administration this is ridiculous one
should be taking Kanye West seriously
he's clearly has issues he's already
been hospitalized joining me with
reaction as Candace Owens communications
director for Turning Point USA Candace
it really turns out that they cannot
accept anyone who disagrees with them
who has any affinity for or any
agreement with President Trump who's the
intolerant one now Candace they are
absolutely intolerant but I'll say this
most especially to add to your statement
most especially black people the
Democrats rely on our vote if they
secured 85 percent of our vote they
would lose so they need to achieve more
than eighty-five percent of the black
vote is to stay in their party so they
have gone through great lengths to smear
Kanye West and what they said last night
was not only racist
it was absolutely despicable and I
cannot believe that it would be allowed
on any network well at least of all
having a host that's laughing as if it's
funny the entire panel kind of just went
on with that imagine if a a conservative
host had a guest on who said something
like that and laugh they would there
would be calls for boycotts I mean I got
in trouble with poor ol LeBron James I
was just teasing I like that sorrow you
can't say it's just it's like you can't
joke but they can say the most horrific
things possible and you know you're
you're shut down what does this mean
though for the Democrat
I think they're worried are they not
Candace I mean you've broken through in
your own way in politics you just kind
of came on the scene with Turning Point
USA there are other people who are
coming forward saying huh
the demonization of Donald Trump and the
Republicans got the economy's doing
really well and maybe the markets down
today but you know this kind of stuff
happens but the stuffs going pretty well
and these people seem really angry all
the time
it kind of doesn't compute at some point
well the anger is masking their
insecurities they are terrified they
were not predicting this they were had
no idea that there was any chance that
conservatives might come after the
cultural war they won the cultural war a
long time ago
so for Kanye West to stand up and to say
that I support Donald Trump that
terrifies them so they're going to say
whatever they can to smear him to make
sure that no other black people wake up
and understand that it has been the left
that has harmed our community it has
been democrat policies that have
rendered our communities in the shape
that they're in today when we talk about
Chicago in Philadelphia and all the
major cities that they have run down
black people are having a mass awakening
and Kanye West is a big part of the
reason why now you've met with Kanye
West I guess you're gonna meet him
tomorrow before his lunch with President
Trump you guys could put struck up
something about friendship what is it
with him and Trump is just you know
they're there they're pals is there a
path toward you know criminal justice
reform prison reform other work they
might do to get kids out of gangs like
what what's the collaboration there look
I don't want to speak for him but I will
tell you my assessment of it after
having several conversations with him
first and foremost Kanye is very
educated about the Democrat Party and
the history of a Democrat Party beyond
that Kanye West really does believe in
uniting both sides and going forward you
know we know the left they want to make
sure that everybody is separate they
want to keep the themes of racism alive
they like fear-mongering Kanye West is
not about any of those things he really
wants to see a world that is better than
the world that we were in yesterday and
he sees a unique opportunity in Donald
Trump because he sees that our president
is courageous he's willing to say the
things that need to be said and we
haven't had that certainly not for the
last eight years when Barack Obama was
in office I think they're terrified of
Kanye West so it's like he's crazy
he's taken
in the same asylum they don't want to
actually argue about the thing which is
the failures of the Democrat Party
candidates all right Candace give us an
update after your after your meeting
tomorrow with Kanye